[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on est passionné d'aviation on
regarde le passé et on dit qu'en fait
c'étaient les années 60 les années 70
qui est l époque rêver à cette époque là
on était dans l'innovation y avait pas
de limites
le ciel n'était plus une limite on voler
à mach 2 dans le concorde
il y avait le ciel qui s'ouvrait la
population il y avait le jumbo jet le
boeing 747 puis des petits plus petit
avion le boeing 707 la caravelle même la
marche sur la lune
on avait la conquête de l'espace il y
avait vraiment pas de limites on avait
des avions fabuleux le sr-71 on était
sur des avions qui ne pouvait que faire
rêver alors évidemment cette innovation
elle a continué
on s'est pas arrêté à ce moment là ça a
progressé doucement de manière
incrémentale mais il ya plus de rupture
tel qu'on l'avait par le passé alors
quand je regarde mon passé et mon
expérience personnelle
ça fait même pas vingt ans que j'ai
commencé ma carrière dans l'aviation
dans l'aviation navale est déjà sur
cette simple période on a réussit
presque à diviser par deux la
consommation de carburant pour
transporter un passager
aujourd'hui quand vous prenez l'avion on
a à peine à 3 litres aux 100 par
passager et dans les compagnies les plus
efficaces avec les avions récents on est
à peine à deux litres aux cent sur cette
période sur ces deux décennies on a
divisé par huit
la probabilité de vivre un accident donc
typiquement aujourd'hui vous faites 5 km
en voiture en france vous avez plus de
chance de vivre un accident mortel que
si vous prenez les 40 pire compagnies
aériennes du monde en termes de sécurité
aérienne donc sur cette simple période
depuis 20 ans on a multiplié par trois
le nombre de passagers on transporte
quatre milliards et demi de personnes
par an et on transporte à peu près un
tiers du fret mondial en termes de
valeur c'est très important
ces gigantesques et le voyage dépens de
l'aviation 90 % des déplacements
internationaux sont réalisés en avions
donc forcément le synonyme de l'évasion
c'est forcément l'avion mais cette
évolution qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent
elles vont pas s'arrêter parce qu'en
réalité il ya plusieurs révolutions qui
arrive la première ça va être les big
data
vous savez simplement pour améliorer ce
bilan carbone on a des possibilités qui
sont quasiment illimitée à partir de
l'information à partir de la météo de la
pluie la pression atmosphérique on va
regarder tout ce qu'il ya autour de nous
est en fait les ordinateurs vous nous
proposez vous proposer aux pilotes une
façon d'accélérer une puissance mais ton
moteur à 93% puissant sur l'autre 95 %
de puissance est là on va économiser 100
kg de carburant au décollage on a
également tout ce qui est autour de la
maintenance jusqu'à présent on
n'attendait qu'une pièce soit cassée
pour la changer
c'était la maintenance trop tard
correctives ou alors on faisait de la
maintenance par anticipation aux gens
cette pièce elle à peu près 90% de son
espérance de vie donc on va la changer
mais aujourd'hui crassous big data on
est capable de définir qu'une pièce va
tomber en panne dans deux semaines et ça
c'est en collectant des données la
pression de thé l'huile le bruit et la
vibration la tension électrique
tout ça ça nous donne information
préventive et ça évite d'avoir des
pannes ça permet de réduire le
changement des pièces on est écologique
on est plus efficace ça est évidemment
tout le monde
il ya d'autres optimisations qui sont
possibles et en plus la période actuelle
dans laquelle on a un petit peu moins
d'avions permet d'accélérer et de tester
de nouvelles procédures par exemple sur
l'atlantique nord
vous savez que normalement on ne fait
pas réellement des lignes droites même
si on est en avion on est toujours
contraint de faire des passages au sol
on survole des aéroports et ça c'est une
réglementation parce qu'on a des
installations qui sont relativement
ancienne et donc les avions ne font pas
des lignes droites et les avions en
réalité ne monte pas à une altitude qui
est optimale pour eux ils sont obligés
de faire des paliers on a en ce moment
la possibilité de tester avec un ciel
qui est plus dégagé que d'habitude de
tester cette nouvelle forme de trafic
aérien et on peut réduire jusqu'à 14 %
les émissions de co2 sur un vol
transatlantique et de la même manière et
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut optimiser
on peut optimiser également tout ce qui
est autour du roulage faire du roulage
électrique plutôt que d'utiliser ces
moteurs qui sont pas très efficaces
et puis on a également les carburants
alternatifs avec un grand paris pour
l'aviation
c'est de prendre des carburants qui soit
réellement durable quand vous prenez de
l'essence avec votre voiture
en fait vous êtes en concurrence avec
l'alimentation parce qu'on utilise
également de de la betterave ou du maïs
ou alors avec la nature ont fait de
l'huile de palme pour faire du carburant
de voitures et l'aviation prend le pari
de
reposé sur rien d'autre que du jus de
poubelle on va récupérer les huiles de
friture on va récupérer tout ce qui est
des déchets agricoles et avec ça on va
faire du carburant réellement durable
donc forcément le défi est un petit peu
plus lointain c'est d'ici la fin de la
décennie on va atteindre des
pourcentages très important mais ont
réduit de 80% les émissions de co2 sur
le cycle du carbone donc c'est très
important
il ya un autre point sur lequel on va
avancer c'est également le poids est ce
que vous savez que si vous alliez aux
toilettes avant de prendre votre avion
en s'allégeant chacun 200 grammes ont
réduit de 50 mille tonnes
la consommation de carburant annuel 150
mille tonnes de co2 seraient économisés
si chacun d'entre nous nous allions aux
toilettes avant d'embarquer
faites ce que vous pouvez pour vous
alléger les entreprises les industriels
les compagnies aériennes également elles
font leurs efforts ils ont des systèmes
pour assécher les avions parce qu'on
peut aller jusqu'à 100 kg d'eau qui vont
s'accumuler derrière les parois par
exemple on va remplacer les vieilles
mal-être de vol par des ipad un ipad ses
quelques kilos les manettes de vol
c'était quasiment 20 kg et donc ça veut
dire que sur chaque journée on va
économiser des dizaines et des dizaines
de kilos de carburant pour chaque avion
et au niveau de la flotte mondiale ça
représente à peu près entre 3 et 4 % de
réduction des émissions co2 avec tout ça
d'ici la fin de la décennie
sans même changer les avions en gardant
exactement les mêmes technologies
on va pouvoir réduire de 20% les
émissions de co2 du secteur aérien
évidemment en plus on va être capable de
moderniser la flotte on va les
renouveler chaque génération d'avion
permet d'avancer de 15 à 20 % donc
remplacer tous les vieux avions par des
nouveaux avions et vous ajoutez tout ces
optimisations qui sont en train
d'arriver
on va atteindre à la fin de la décennie
d efficacité qui sont jamais vu par le
passé parce que c'est peut-être ça la
limite la limite c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
voit bien que l'aviation émet du co2
l'aviation elle produit énormément de
richesse évidemment elle aimait à peu
près 2% du gaz à effet de serre
mondiales
c'est beaucoup mais en réalité c'est peu
par rapport à la richesse qu'elle
produit
elle produit 4% du pib elle permet aux
peuples de se retrouver elle permet aux
gens de voyager elle permet au tourisme
aux professionnels et aux familles de se
retrouver
donc c'est absolument indispensable et
vous savez ce qui est le plus formidable
c'est que toutes ces évolutions qu'on
voit c'est encore rien par rapport à la
vraie révolution quand on est en train
de voir
la première c'est l'électrification pour
la première fois cette année dernière on
a un avion 100 % électrique qui a été
certifié
alors il est petit ça permet de voler
autour d'un aéroclub de faire des tours
de piste pour les écoles par exemple
mais ça c'est le début d'une vraie
révolution
cette année en 2021 pour la première
fois vous avez une compagnie aérienne au
canada à rebours air qui va utiliser des
avions d'ancienne génération sur lequel
ils vont
j'ai les moteurs pour pouvoir faire des
vols 100% électrique le grand avantage
évidemment c'est que vous émettez plus
de co2 mais l'autre avantage c'est que
ça réduit de 60% les coûts d'utilisation
de votre appareil
ça va rouvrir le ciel à des gens qui
jusqu'à présent avaient des limitations
écologique est aussi économique
le fait de voler va devenir de moins en
moins cher ça c'est que le début 2021
ensuite vous avez des appareils de plus
en plus moderne et plus en plus gros
2023 9 sièges 1000 km ensuite on va
continuer à grossir à la fin de la
décennie on va arriver ces appareils qui
seront autour de 70 sièges
après les avions purement électrique on
aura également les hybrides électriques
c'est une technologie qui est un petit
peu entre les deux qui permet par
exemple de faire le début de son vol le
décollage la partie la plus polluante en
100% électrique puissions ensuite en vol
de croisière utiliser les moteurs
thermiques pour faire d'électricité
qu'on va utiliser le moteur est là on
est en dessous de 1 litre aux 100 par
passager on a ensuite les avions qui
vont être de plus en plus gros donc on
va passer sur les avions de 20 sièges en
2025 70 sièges à la fin de la décennie
et vous avez des projets très ambitieux
qui à partir de 2030 de pourra avoir
jusqu'à 180 passagers sur à peu près
1000 km alors mille kilomètres se donne
l'impression que ce n'est pas beaucoup
mais en réalité ce court courriers ça
représente plus de 50% des routes
mondiales et ça représente plus de 25%
des émissions de co2 mondiales
donc quand on pourra remplacer ces vols
polluants parce que les avions sont pas
optimisés pour faire des trajets si
court par des vols 100% électrique
évidemment ça va être une vraie
révolution la deuxième grande révolution
ça va être les drones taxi ce qu'on
appelle les ive et hall verticale des
cov landing les systèmes qui vont
décoller de votre jardin pour vous
amener plus ou moins là où vous voulez
alors ça c'est une vision un petit peu
futuriste évidemment ça va commencer
tout doucement mais c'est pas pendant
très longtemps
imaginez les premiers drones taxi à
utilisation commerciale pourrait arriver
dès cette année en chine en 2022 ce sera
singapour et dubaï en 2023 à los angeles
san francisco en 2024
ce sera à paris et là on aura une
liberté qui sera énorme
dans un premier temps évidemment ça va
être des lignes qui seront relativement
réduite on ira de disneyland jusqu'à
l'aéroport de charles de gaulle mais
ensuite petit à petit ça va se massifier
il y en aura de plus en plus
on estime qu'il y aura quinze mille
drones taxi en 2035 dans le monde on
aura déjà besoin de 60 mille pilotes de
drones taxi d'ici la fin de la décennie
et ça va être très avantageux notamment
parce que le coup sera très faible
peluches et moins cher que prendre un
über est quelque chose de très
avantageux également c'est qu'on a un
bruit qui sera particulièrement faibles
plus faible qu'un camion qui passerait
dans votre rue donc on a vraiment une
révolution qui va arriver une simplicité
qui va s'ouvrir avec des trajets qui
vont être permis dans des zones
relativement isolées jusqu'à présent
sans moyen de transport pour un prix qui
va être dérisoire
l'autre avantage des drones c'est tout
ce qui est autour de la livraison
parce qu objectivement l'aviation va
aussi permettre de réduire les émissions
de co2 des autres secteurs la livraison
aujourd'hui ça représente des milliers
de camionnettes qui sont pas forcément
bien optimisé qui réalisent des trajets
qui sont pas forcément en ligne droite
et les systèmes de livraison par drones
taxi ça va être une vraie révolution
parce qu'on va pouvoir optimiser tout ce
système et toute cette logistique
notamment la logistique du dernier
kilomètre
vous avez perdu votre téléphone au fin
fond du laos vous allez vous faire
livrer sa part drones taxi l'exemple que
je présente ici c'est notamment ce qu'on
voit au rwanda le rwanda a besoin
d'aller à mener des poches de sang par
exemple dans des hôpitaux de campagne
qui sont relativement loin le fait de le
faire en voiture c'est particulièrement
compliqué et donc depuis maintenant
plusieurs années dans les pays dans
laquelle la réglementation permet de
faire des tests
on est déjà sur la livraison
opérationnel pour des produits médicaux
tout simplement pour accélérer les
choses ça coûte moins cher la troisième
révolution ça va être celle de
l'hydrogène mikko vous en parlera mieux
que moi juste après mais le grand
avantage de l'hydrogène s'est évidemment
qu'il n'émet pas de co2 on est sur un
système qui est totalement propre
on aimait de la vapeur d'eau ont réduit
les traînées de condensation il ya plus
de 2 de particules fines
il n'y a plus rien qui soit réellement
polluants donc il va falloir la produire
cet hydrogène mais la réalité c'est qu'à
partir de 2035 notamment airbus va
sortir et va proposer cet appareil qui
sera sans aucune émission de co2 il y
aura plus de barrières on aura la
possibilité de voyager sans se poser de
questions on va pouvoir reprendre le
chemin des aires sans se poser de
questions il y aura plus la honte de
volée et tous les mouvements qu'on voit
aujourd'hui auront disparu à ce moment
là
et le dernier point c'est aussi qu'on
voit que ces avions qui vont sortir à
partir de cette période ont une
architecture qui va être totalement
nouvelle on a les moteurs qui sont
ouverts beaucoup plus efficace on a des
formes qui vont être moderne regarder un
petit peu à quoi ça ressemble avec les
moteurs qui sont directement un briquet
encastré à l'intérieur des ailes les
formes du futur permettront également de
gagner entre 15 et 20% de réduction des
émissions de co2 et quand vous accumulez
l'électrification l'hydrogène les formes
du futur et une réorganisation du ciel
vraiment vous êtes persuadé qu'on va
réussir ce challenge parce que le vrai
challenge l'aviation c'est de réussir ce
en quoi il s'est engagé dès capable
d'accueillir trois fois plus de
passagers tout en divisant par 3 les
émissions co2 net du secteur d'ici 2050
c'est un vrai challenge
on va vraiment le réussir et maintenant
je vous demande d'imaginer votre voyage
comment vous allez voyager en 2040 en
europe
vous habitez au fin fond de la creuse
vous voulez aller en bulgarie ça va être
simple un drone taxi viendra vous
chercher
il vous amène au petit aéroport ce drone
taxi le raj à vérifier que vous avez
tous les équipements de sécurité que
vous n'avez pas de bombe sur vous qui a
pas d'un jeu en explosifs votre identité
aura déjà été vérifiée
donc quand vous arriverez à l'aéroport
vous serez directement cette zone de
bien la lettre de confort votre bulle de
sécurité
il ya un petit robot qui va venir vous
chercher qui va venir vous demander
votre bagage ça va être automatisées
évidemment donc on est sur un système
qui est facile vous allez embarquer dans
cet avion qui n'émet pas de co2 vous
allez aller à l'autre bout de l'europe
et ça c'est l'engagement être capable de
réaliser 90 % des trajets européen de
porte à porte en moins de quatre heures
on est vraiment à la veille d'une
révolution
et maintenant réfléchissez un petit peu
on est aujourd'hui en train de vivre
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
il ya des dizaines et des milliers de
générations avant nous qui ont rêvé de
pouvoir voler on est les premiers qui
ont cette chance
hier on a vécu quelque chose qui était
une première révolution on a ouvert le
ciel à la terre entière
demain va arriver la nouvelle révolution
est là on va être capable de voler sans
se poser de questions ça va être beau
parce que tout simplement le ciel va
être ouvert donc vraiment l'âge d'or de
l'aviation il n'est pas dans les années
60 70
l'âge d'or de l'aviation il est devant
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]